hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the top chess engine Championship season
superfinal this is game three between
Leela chess zero on the white end and
stockfish this one was played on October
11th and there are a few miniature
positional lessons to take away from it
the opening King's Indian
defense pay special attention to the
king
Knight this is one of the things I found
instructive with this game how Leela
Maneuvers the king Knight in the zish
variation we're not quite at the start
position of this one eight moves are
played before we reach that start
position I'll just be making some light
notes until we get there this being the
First Once black exerts pressure on D4
if White's going to support that point
it should be with the Knight the king
Knight If instead of the king Knight you
go with the bishop black would enjoy
this Tempo Knight C6 and the
bishop uh is going to have to move or at
least should move here so we can say
Knight G to E2 white supports D4 with
the Fearless minor piece no problems now
if there's a capture and Knight C6 we
would continue to
develop in the game it is castles Bishop
Bop G5 C6 and after a couple Queen moves
we reach our start position stockfish
has just unpinned the Knight first move
of the game is D5 space for Leela on the
Queen's side Black's approach is to try
and overtake this invasive Pawn by
chipping away at the queenside structure
so A6 and B5 is right around the corner
how to continue from here let's have a
look at the king Knight right away it no
longer serves a useful rule on E2
there's no capture on D4 to worry about
nothing to support anymore currently
it's simply boxed out by a silly Pawn
it's time to reposition plus the light
Square Bishop wants to have a move King
Knight drifts towards the queen side has
an eye on both B3 and D3 three in the
event of B5 it likes to follow up Knight
B3 with Tempo in this game the queen
goes back
voluntarily and the Knight arrives on
D3 both white Knights are an excellent
squares we consider the key 16 squares
on the board let's key in
on this guy though what role or roles
does it
serve a couple squares come to mind for
me currently watches over
C5 that's nice because Black's Queen
Knight may want to Pivot there one day
and also it watches over F4 Black's King
Knight may want to Pivot there in some
cases okay anything
else well after black carries on with
this idea to break down White's Queen
side structure after B5 is in we can
note something
more right now there's no worry of any
lines where B4 is played to kick the
Knight away watches over
B4 the continuation is to take on
B5 black takes towards the center and
this guy is not done moving it goes to
B4 increases the pressure on C6 what's
going to happen soon D5 is going to open
up for one of these Knights Knights also
one of Black's pawns is going to
fall okay we continue Bishop
D7 Bishop takes Knight recapture capture
on
C6 Knight takes C6 Knight B to D5 kicks
the queen back home to defend the bishop
let's pause for a moment 16 moves in a
lot of King Knight moves so far 1 2 3 3
4 5 Where Do We Go From Here how would
you continue in this
position feel free to pause the
video okay instructive moment in the
game you would
think let's keep the Knight on this D5
Square it's almost always going to be a
terrible idea to trade this Knight for
this dark Square Bishop what's
considered a bad Bishop but there's a
concrete reason why white does make this
exchange right
here let's see what that reason is let's
see what happens if you don't take the
bishop here and instead let's say
develop a new piece and take the B
Pawn there's this check on H4 that's
irritating you don't want to go un
castled and if you play
G3 black can now pounce on this weakness
the weakness of the last move there's
Knight D4 how you defending F3 let's say
Bishop E2 how you dealing with this
diagonal
F4 okay this here is as far as I'm going
to take it you could see you could kind
of
feel really the compensation for the
pawn we have an invasive light Square
Bishop in White's Camp a knight as well
not so easy to get rid of these pieces
there's a pin here in as well and how
comfortable is it for white to have
these pawns both up a step when there's
still all of these pieces on board there
has only been one exchange so
far how to prevent this active play by
black well you swipe the bishop you
eliminate Bishop H4
check white will won't have to play
G3 Queen takes Knight only now do you
take on
B5 Rook
C8 castles no fear of Knight D4 here the
bishop would hang Bishop E6 Pop Quiz
what would you play here feel free to
pause the
video okay in the game it's Bishop takes
Knight if you swipe another Pawn this
Knight gets to
D4 it likes this as a second best idea
to take the pawn but now how are you
getting rid of this Knight causing you
could very easily see this Knight cause
you
problems so you just swipe the Knight a
simple approach don't even allow a black
piece to be
maintained on your side of the board
Bishop takes Knight it is white is up
the pawn and we're playing a knight
versus Bishop
position Rook on F to
C1 Queen d8 nearby there's Queen B6
check when that check is in there how to
react to it let's say you were forced to
make a king move you certainly don't
want to go towards the center there's
followup checks there's still way too
many pieces around to move towards the
center and you really don't want to go
to the corner either although that would
be the better choice of the two what's
best of all is the H2 square and white
is very timely here is in a spot to meet
the check with King H2 that is the
coziest Square for the
king H3 on board Rook B8 King
H2 Queen A5 A3 preps B4 looking to get
this
connected uh looking to get the
connected pass pawns rolling black stops
that and let's see how to reposition the
pieces there really isn't a way for
black to break down the ABC files
there's only one point white has to
watch over and that is uh
B2 right now there is this threat to
trap The Rook so the queen is out of the
way so the bishop so The Rook can
move okay we have all Rooks on the C
file Rook D2 Bishop B3 stopping the
doubling Queen
F2 H5
H4 yeah you really don't want this this
Pawn to be established on H4 not that it
was a threat right away
but H4 on board fix this Pawn on a light
Square Rook
B8 now this leaves black tactically
vulnerable we're going to have a pair of
Rooks exchanged here Knight A2 is the
followup no time for Bishop takes Knight
there would be Rook takes on C6 I
questioned what are we doing if
these Rooks stay trained on the C file
how does white make progress here just
want to give you a feel for how you can
play as white if there's two Rooks on
board it suggests getting off of the C
file and then trying to stack the Rooks
like this can't go to the D1
Square also there is this idea and that
is an F4 break these are ways forward
for white
okay in the game we get a pair of Rooks
exchanged and also a queen exchange so
the D Pawn is now a c pawn and this guy
helps defend against the connected
passers from
Rolling how to approach this we need to
get the king
involved currently this is
a passive versus active Rook on active
there is some AC it but it has this
defensive
role White's approach here is to have
the king babysit the B Pawn so that the
Rook is free to do some other stuff so
we get this little uh king walk towards
the queen side the Knight is also in a
spot to stop any disruptive C3 move to
break up the pawn
Duo Knight on
C3 maintain the pawn on
H4 if White initiates this
capture you could maybe at some stage
see the king go to G6 maybe there's G5
King G5 King F4 at some stage by
maintaining this Pawn here this is under
control this is under control these two
are occupied there's no progress for the
King on uh the king's side of the
board so it is simply
G3 A4 here goes the white king
to watch over the B Pawn now this Rook
is
free P Pawn is created on the E file for
black but white already has the passer
the a pawn takes a step we have a check
continues to advance right around the
corner possible Fork ideas with
promotion Rook C8 Knight B6 Rook G8 and
the followup here is Knight takes on C4
I wondered why not just push A7 here
isn't it just going to be a rook for
pawn exchange soon enough this is a way
you could go but do know that there is
this pesky E3 move and we have the Rook
hit and the bishop is a step away now
from controlling that promotion
Square so the approach here is to grab
the C4 Pawn Stop This advance
there are connected passers they're a
bit away
but okay the a pawn ends up getting
Tracked Down eventually meanwhile this
this Rook goes after the center pawns
important to not only defend the knight
in this position but get out of the pin
as well if you go here instead there's
E3 so King
B3 Rook A8 we get the check white gives
up the a pawn but goes hunting for the
others and will soon be back to up a um
back to up two pawns here grabs the H
Pawn so before it was just the A3 and B2
Pawn connected passers now we have H4
and
G3 and any uh any time white is given to
advance the pawns starts pushing the
Pawns not too difficult to technique
from here there's only one critical
moment to touch on coming up this is a
95 move
game um you just one critical moment
ahead and it's pretty
clean so in the game it is Rook A1 here
if the Rook goes after the G Pawn simple
enough we can
defend Rook A1 after Rook H7 I wondered
well wait a second if the Rook goes to
G1 now how are we defending
this guy
exactly there's a threat here after The
Rook is on the seventh rank if the Rook
goes after the G Pawn we don't have to
spend any time defending the
pawn this bishop will be one with a
check doesn't matter where the King goes
the Knight goes to F6 next with check
defending the rook and there goes the
bishop this helps explain why Rook F1 is
played there is no Knight maneuver to F6
now we continue with B4 improve the King
this is the last critical moment of the
game there's only one winning
continuation I wonder if you can spot it
feel free to pause the
video okay in the game it is Knight
G6 if you try some other Square for
instance Knight C6 there's Rook F3 and
this Pawn is going to fall this is
considered a uh a
draw B4 we can
take uh what what happens if the Knight
goes to D7 the king could go to G8
Target the rook and right around the
corner there's this Fork
idea so it is Knight G6
check King G8 met with the Counterattack
Rook
E7 some defense of the bishop Knight E5
Bishop D5 and the pawns just get rolling
basically at this
stage King perfect blockader the Knight
also watches out for two possible pivots
by The Rook nice and cozy for white and
these pawns simply continue to roll
gaining steam with check nice little
wall formed here just in time to stop a
check no great king advances in this
position all right let's see these final
moves two connected pass pawns on the
sixth now a funny move coming up
blocking the check with Knight D3 not
sure why exactly you can make basically
any other
move um okay Rook takes Knight with
check there's no good follow-up check
here no Pawn Advance either plenty of
ways to do it at this
stage some silly checks thrown in and
there's a
queen and we get this funny move seen
this one before with these engine games
you ready Queen d8 giving up giving away
the queen so that we could get another
queen with check Landing a skewer okay
we get just a few more moves in after
Rook C6 and queen takes Rook brings us
to a table base win for
white what did you think of this one
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care
bye